So what exactly does GeoJSON look like especially once we load it in with d3?
Just as with our previous charts, we simply set up our margins, our width and
our height and we append an SVG element this time with class map to our page.
And now we can put in a debugger, so we can pause execution and
expect what geo data looks like and the structure it has.
As you can see here we've loaded our globe.html file, that we were just
looking at in the browser and execution has paused at line 22 in the debugger.
Looking at what geo data is you can see here.
There is a JavaScript object with top level keys,
type with value feature collection and features that corresponds to an array.
And again, another one of the benefits of using geoJSON is that it
simply a JSON file that we can pass around like any other.
In this case, we can even load it in with
d3's standard JSON data loading function, and when we inspect it in our console,
we can see here the Crowoop console treats it like any other JSON and
gives us this nested structure to inspect through.
We can see here that in the features array there's 177 items.
Each of which it's self is an object that has a geometry key and properties key.
The properties in this case as a single key
value pair is the name of the country.
In this case the first one is Afghanistan.
What makes GeoJSON unique is it's shape extensions.
Here we can see each country has a geometry key
that corresponds to an object that both has coordinates and the type,
in this case the geometry of a country is a polygon, as we can see here.
And coordinates is an array of values, or
rather an array of arrays of two elements or
pairs of coordinates representing the longitude and latitude of the country.
One thing to note here, and it's not explicit,
is that longitude actually comes first, in this case what's labelled with zero,
and latitude comes second, what's labelled as one here.
And that's just a quirk of the format.
And there's geometry object that has coordinate points and the type,
polygon represents the border of a country, in this case, Afghanistan